[Music]
adonis is destined for greatness he has
something that most sighted people don't
have and that's vision he has a vision
of his future he has a vision of what he
wants in this world and he's not afraid
to get it having sight or not having
sight doesn't really matter to me
there's no room for fear
[Music]
so technically I guess you could sound
completely blind in my mind it's almost
like a TV us running 24/7 images flash
it's basically like I can see him even
though I really can't it's like an
illusion in a way it's an early child
Adonis was so jovial he was laughter all
the time he signed him up for football
he bought his cleats that morning we
went swimming that was the day he lost
his eyesight so he never actually wore
the cleats on the field wonder why I
came up in October you see he has a very
rare congenital glaucoma one in 10,000
kids have this and it just so happened
that I was there alone with him in the
pool it could have happened at any time
nice like I want to say three or four
years I had 12 12 I say geez I hated him
I would wake up it was like I didn't
have an intro of nothing I was just woke
up by just crying for no reason
good take for granted like the street or
the guys at the sky
you know he's regular stuff like that
I'm sorry he says mom you gotta get
ready get back in the field I wanted to
say they're not gonna accept you
they're not gonna let you play and I
said to him you're gonna get hit on your
Blind Side
he says mom on my sides of nine I know
that the only challenge I could I really
remember was again my parents listened
to me more it will help me back time to
find a way convince them so just let me
go other people probably do put limits
on me it's just because they don't know
no better
Sekou
you know blind people you think that
like Stevie Wonder and like Ray Charles
and audience I'm playing football and
doing basketball I run a track and doing
all this like athletic stuff to play
basketball I lied on my phone with the
net and it scooted back so it's like
under the backboard
then I'll play music and I'll use the
music to aim I'm shooting it
[Music]
if there was a miracle to happy
I probably into playing basketball
because this would be honest I got the
body of her basketball player and far
when bond I was always hoping
[Music]
I've tried to trick him I've tried to
delay him I tried to put him into my
support
he will not be blocked even if life
football I was playing I was always
playing setting here so I mean I ain't
really gets a I get the ball and so far
I was like 9 or 10 when he lost his
eyesight he gained a whole new vision
for his life he sees himself just like
the strongest the biggest fastest the
smartest the most agile the kid really
believes he's unstoppable there we go
big breath in and exhale as you come
back up right side there we go
and down to me football has always been
for was gonna be football I'm gonna get
faster you're stronger will get bigger
it wasn't even a thought of quitting
working on really strength stability
balance or proprioception later on down
the line it's going to have to be
building mass because he's gonna take
some hits because he's not gonna be able
to see everything coming at him using
the canes kind of like an ongoing thing
you never like perfect at it but I guess
you say I took me for maybe five years
wet barrel in general learn how to read
and write probably sent me like three
years to be pretty good at it
all right here says I'm going to the NFL
as far as using my phone I was cool
after like two weeks so nobody can hear
what I'm texting who I'm saying I speed
up the speech whenever on top it says
what I taught I bet you remember every
letter in the keyboard so I'll just text
like anybody else and it says about X
face
a lot of this stuff as far as knowing
where things is just guessing games and
I'll know if it's like the feeling but
it's like something goes off in my brain
like an alarm saying I've been here
before when you here as a football coach
that you're gonna have a blind athlete
come in and want to play football it was
challenging the thought of somebody
playing a position like running back not
being able to see it's hard to wrap your
mind around
if you honest I don't think they
completely completely believed I can
play running back he doesn't want
anything given to him and when you know
when we told the officials in his first
game where he scored a touchdown he
scored that touchdown based on a team
making very sportsmanlike action by
letting him score but everybody around
him knew that's not what he wanted when
we went into the next game we didn't
really tell anybody any score two
touchdowns it was all earned
[Music]
like he's not breaking records he's
setting records like he's the first
first the first the first the first the
first innit
I remember having to actually push
through somebody and how do like almost
dive in it was pretty good knowing I
could do it when somebody was actually
trying to start it imagine that in your
head there was no other option but to
run forward and to run into that song
that's where Adonis's he has no choice
we talked about trust all the time you
know I used to play quarterback I had to
trust trust my receivers are gonna be in
the right spot trust those five guys up
front that they were gonna block their
guy and that was with full vision to
trust those guys without vision know
when somebody's trying to hit you I mean
it's it's phenomenal I mean my teammate
is a big part cuz you can't be by
yourself and we you know you need all 11
guys to do to do their job to know that
they got my back it was pretty cool one
of the big things we stress here is
trust him following us around putting
his hand on our shoulder all of us look
at that and we trust each other just a
little bit more in football you could
send to like really get selfish and
focus on yourself but when you have
something like Adonis there you
recognize the importance of teamwork and
helping the fellow brother out
I remember one practice I was just
messing around and I like try to I close
my eyes and I was running through the
plays and it was scary really scary so I
just admire how fearless he is he
doesn't let him being by an effect
anything that he does like it's just
inspiring to see the more I spent time
with Adonis or more his blindness
disappeared and the more I just saw him
as the Donais the football player
blesses Adonis the blind football
what I like best is probably how hard
you have to work how it's just not given
to you y'all be somebody that's gonna be
be able to go to a stream I can't go out
on a pass it's tough to see where
litters coming from so we got to limit
what we're doing but last year you
scored several touchdowns in short
yardage situations and about what we can
do that again in 2019 after high school
I'm hopefully go to a d1 school and a
scholarship
after I produced there hopefully I can
get to the NFL and uh get some rings and
play for a long time I've had thoughts
of being in a game winning situation on
the one-yard line how awesome would it
be to have a Donnison to score that
Dutchman
in his face actually has been a light
that guides me through his darkness but
for next week Tuesday morning perfect
alright alright these are the darkness
right
I mean I think I would've ended up the
way I am right now anyway
blind tonight saw me I guess you could
say giving it it gave me a little extra
play about me it didn't like make too
much of a difference who always going to
end up being anyway this is Rafi's
number 21 adonis watch we brought you
this story last year a blind freshman
running back on the Freshman team and
tonight making his varsity debut scores
from a yard out yeah that special that's
big-time Congrats to abdominus what
Brophy stays
[Music]
how're you guys doing today
I appreciate you guys let me come in
anybody know where my man Adonis is
[Applause]
you don't well yes sir no when I heard
about you men I I got to go over and
meet my guy I gotta I gotta see this man
you're much taller than I thought y'all
might call it it means you know it'll
just be the two of us on the team of the
only two guys that have ever played ball
rain oh well you're right I got em one
up on you they're good being blind since
he was five years old he's never given
up his passion for sports and that's
what's inspiring to me I played football
since I was his age and I couldn't
imagine not being a little to see but
the darkness is beating all the I's
teammates are helping them be able to
live his dream as well and that's what I
love about sports so this you have 16 or
17 so how you how you play so long the
Lord Lord been good to me
dönitz we were on the football field
where you scored your touchdowns I want
to play a little quarterback so I want
to reenact it I'm ready when you are
let's go let's do it all right all right
Donna she bought the snap it all right
hey line me up so I'm good yeah you're
good you're good
say go good job brother
good job the appreciate you let me come
out here and practice a couple plays
with you you're a wonderful young man
and a true inspiration and thank you for
letting me come out here and be a part
of your day all right man thanks for
coming out here man
absolutely pleasure it's a pleasure
I'm Larry Fitzgerald and this is
bleacher report